so as the costume designer for both
seasons of this show can you talk about
sort of the biggest challenges that you
have when it comes to working with the
show and transitioning from the first
season to the second season the biggest
challenge is trying to not up your game
too much that you just take everybody
out of a world that was pretty perfectly
crafted I'd say in first season and so
that you just feel that it's a
continuation to um the first
season because you're I would say I've
never designed a second season before
but my first tendency and I think it's
just a natural tendency is to think that
you've got to sort of top yourself so um
but then you quickly realize or I
quickly realize that I that these are
characters and this is a world and that
the audiences become quite attached to
and that you
the most important part of my process is
to honor that and to continue telling
that same story so that it is difficult
because you're you're you want to
maintain that you want it to feel
seamless and that it's a a real
continuation of the same story yeah I
mean obviously at when we're at the TVA
I think it's everybody's sort of dressed
in I wouldn't say like a well some of
them are in uniform but they all have
like a very um homogeneous look and I've
noticed that there's little details on
everybody's um like clothing that kind
of like singles them out as a person is
there um how do you how do you go about
that process of sort of customizing each
um like uniform or costume for each of
these characters in this homogenized
space in the re in some of the original
research for the first season of Loki I
looked at a lot of NASA um photographs
and just what people did in the what
what people were wearing when it was
like the moon launch and control Command
Center and the different variations even
though it there's obviously a dress code
and just how people personalize things
right um no matter what it's like giving
a kid a school uniform they're always
going to personalize it so um my
approach to just there was all there
there was that element of like yes we
can the TBA can strip away all of your
past and sort of make you just this
worker be and this sort
of uh social structure but
um but you're there's always going to be
a little tendency to personalize and
then also just this there was there was
also the consideration of hierarchies
and trying to really create some levels
of hierarchy within that system yeah
definitely I mean I also noticed that
all of the ties have a square bottom
which I thought was very interesting for
all the characters um so when we're
looking at this full season I mean there
have been some amazing costumes I think
especially in this most recent episode
where we're going back to the World Fair
it's everybody's got an amazing I mean I
love rona's costume the most I think she
looks amazing um but do you have um do
you have an episode that you were the
most excited to sort of see come to life
I would say I was really excited to see
the the episode come to life for sure I
mean of course there's ones that I can't
talk about but um 100% um love was so
looking forward to seeing how it would
all work together and to and how we how
the Midway because we worked really hard
in trying to be as authentic to the
World's Fair as possible and give it
still a Loki feel so I think we managed
to do both those things um um but in
saying that I also really enjoyed doing
the 70s because I thought it was a great
um segue from the TVA having just been
in the TVA for that amount of time in
episode one to then just be rocketed
into a dramatically different and
glamorous
World um felt like really right for the
story and really fun to do costume wise
to get a little glamour in and
especially like with Wy to be able to
give her moment spent out yeah oh that's
true she did she had a great costume in
that in that scene too um when it comes
to dressing these this cast I mean
obviously each character has their own
personality like we were saying um do
you how how do you approach it when it
comes to their specific wardrobe like
for the actor specifically or the
characters do is there does each person
have like a color scheme or is there
like a recurring theme yes because it
all comes from their character right so
for instance Tom
there are just things that a Loki and
Loki is going to choose aesthetically I
think that are so built into that
character and also just built into Tom's
physicality right so like the turning up
of the collar the way things fit uh the
silhouette is always so specific to Tom
um and with like a Sylvie I think that
her character always needs to feel like
it's on the run and um so I think the
movement in the clothing is always
important and the Aging of her clothing
is always important to make it feel that
she has been there's history because um
there is
history and I think that her uh and also
her Swagger as a character I think
always comes from that that
androgynous sort of Mobility um uh and
always kind of ready for battle even if
she wants to live a regular life there's
always some part of her that's on edge
um and I I really do love I do love
her
androgyny um yeah I mean I this season I
love that big coat that she's wearing
too like the little I think it's like
hounds tooth coat that she has over
everything it's very like comfortable
but also like she's ready to leave at
any moment
right exactly exactly and and and a nod
to her trying to live her a Loki version
of a normal life um and the hounds tooth
being a little bit of a nod to the 80s
yeah definitely um it's a great it's a
great costume and I like when she just
snaps and she goes back to her old her
old outfit it's like okay yeah she's
always ready to to get into
action and and then in response to the
ren Slayer I think that she's always
straddled in character-wise what does
strength mean in terms of masculine and
feminine and what are Silhouettes uh
that uh reflects strength that can be
both masculine and feminine I so I think
uh with her costume even in this
season there the color Choice leans into
that a little bit has both can kind of
straddle both ma a masculine and a
feminine side and then the the suit
itself is actually a bicycle riding suit
from that era it's actually pants which
is oh
kolots okay I love that I did not really
that they were pants yeah and it um that
they existed in the era but women didn't
really wear pants in that era but except
for those so okay okay um there's
obviously a wide range of Styles as
we're going through this show um in
season one as well as two because we're
obviously jumping through time but when
you're kind of looking for inspiration
for this show do you turn to anything
other than you know obviously historical
documentation and things like that is
there some there that you're always like
okay this is where I can go to sort of
re up my creative juices so to speak I
definitely love a fabric store I think
fabric stores textiles textiles always
give me a lot of inspiration but so does
art for color palette
for texture for what
um uh I think that trying to think in
specific like in the season one just
going to that brutalist like really
looking towards like a brutalist
language was very helpful and all those
details you pointed out in the TVA
uniform um so and of course talking to
the production designer is also another
huge part of my references but um yeah I
I and I like to
also um dig deep into real real life
inspiration like real people from
history to use that as a a launching
Point as well yeah I mean I think uh
it's it's really fun to see sort of your
Twist on it because obviously these are
not characters who live in the time so
they kind of have like little touches of
like not modernity but I guess like out
of time sort of asynchronous style so I
I really I enjoyed that a lot um just
looking at this show obviously there are
many characters do you have a favorite
character that you like to dress or you
look forward to designing you know
thinking up ideas for well that's just
such a tough question because I think
every one I just for me so much of a CO
of costume designing is so in the moment
so every every single one I do I think
is my favorite
one B basically but it has been really
funed to travel through this with um
obviously with Tom and
Sophia um and just go through that go
through season one and season two with
them has been yeah I love the green
accents on all the lokis that's my
favorite part to sort of look for like
oh there's some piping there that's
green and like you know a little bit of
that personality yes yeah yeah that's
really and do you have like a favorite
piece from season 2 because obviously
there's a lot I mean I love those kolots
but maybe there's something else that
you you um you enjoyed you know sort of
seeing uh in the character so to
speak I did but well I loved um Tom's 7s
tuxedo but I also really loved um
General
Doc's uniform in the war room because
there's this and I don't know that very
visible uh from the the camera angle but
the um the details her her swag on her
shoulders is actually um the timekeepers
it's actually it's beaded it's all
beaded The Time Keeper heads oh oh wow
on her on her like yes oh my gosh I need
to go back and take a look at that oh
it's hard to see but the it's um from
that angle but yes that I I would say
there's details on that costume that are
so magnificently
crafted um I just wish you could see it
more I always I always feel that like
once I see the picture the like when
they display costumes like oh there's
like all these little things that I wish
we got to see you know a little bit
closer they could just linger the camera
there a little you know couple minutes
um so I was was just talking to kazer
and I talked to uh dandelo last week and
they both obviously have um roles in
this show that are not directing but
they are directors do you have any
aspirations for directing next or is it
just you know you're fine where you are
with costuming you've got a lot on your
hands I guess I'd love to direct I mean
I definitely I I would say I think I
even told somebody on on our flag means
death I was like can I just do season
can I direct to season two um well only
only things that I know so uh I
characters I know so well I feel that
there's a real value to knowing these
characters so well when you get to do
multiple Seasons or you even just one
really tough season of a show and
especially as a costume designer you're
you are really carving out what those
characters are going to be and where
they're going to go so you get to you
have to get to know them if you're doing
your job well as a costume designer
you're getting to know them really
well to inform Your Design decisions
yeah definitely I mean I have to say I
we're not here to talk about our flag
means death but I love our flag means
death and costuming in that show is also
amazing um I just you know I can't I
can't say enough good things about your
work and um I can't wait to see what
else you have in store for the rest of
the season I know you can't spoil it but
I'm looking forward to it very much um I
just want to thank you for speaking with
me and taking the time to talk with me
and um thank you very much thank you
thank
you